could you raise your hand if you have
seven seven vertices hands up few people
who's got more than seven
has anyone got fewer than seven sevens
like our bottom number yeah okay now we
can definitely represent this with seven
I'm going to put one's out so I'll go
back I'm gonna put ones like sort of see
these like these junctions here I think
those were a place where a lot of us put
a Evert a vertex right and then you put
them along put them along all that kind
of thing which is fine right now
remember these bridges of königsberg
these one two three four five six seven
the bridges are what I'm really focused
on now just have a look for example
suppose I'm just going to go to this one
it's a bit easier for just for you to
see suppose I put a vertex here and a
vertex here which I think a lot of you
have done right
what's the edge or where is the edge
that joins these it's kind of along here
right now
this edge is not a bridge is it that's a
lot of bridge so I don't mind putting it
there it's still an accurate
representation but it's actually extra
information I don't really need because
the bridges are the things that I'm
focused on okay so I'm actually going to
suggest we can do this with way fewer
than seven or even eight I think we can
do it with four watch I'm gonna get rid
of some of these so you may want to do
this perhaps in your book cause you've
probably drawn all over and what I've
done is I've like lightened this so it's
easier for me to see and hopefully for
you to see as well sorry I'm just gonna
this might help is that any better
okay cool sorry I want a natural light
before but that's not helpful if you can
see all right so here's where I'm gonna
start to put vertices all right I think
we all know you got this island here in
the middle and then you're gonna this
other island so we clearly have to go
back and forth between the islands like
we're crossing bridges right so I've got
two so far I'm suggesting I only need to
put two more can anyone suggest to me
where are that put one yeah we can no
two middle ones okay so when you say
middle what do you mean by middle can
you be more descriptive
a top in the middle and bottom in the
middle okay
now I'm up to four which is much fewer
than many of the other you guys had but
I think if you follow with me and maybe
draw this long with you I think we can
represent every bridge using just these
four vertices let's give it a go let's
start with the first two vertices that
we drew so there's a bridge between them
right so it goes like that okay remember
because I'm just caring about how you
cross the bridges I don't care like
we're in this island I am I don't care
from the top of the bottom I just care
that I'm on the island is that all right
cool so I've got that middle one one
bridge down six To Go
okay how am I going to get the rest of
them on there well some of them are easy
to see like I can go from this island
here and then I can get from the same
island up like that
now just staying with this guy I've got
three bridges coming out of it
how many more bridges have I got left
just from that particular vertex yeah
drive one more which one is there
another one there are two up there one
goes up what goes down okay so I'm going
to draw this one over here whoops sorry
wrong tool so the drew goes all the way
up to here now a lot of we us drew an
extra vertex C but do you see it doesn't
really need to be there because you're
still going to cross that bridge all the
information is captured okay and then
where was the last bridge from this guy
it's down the bottom right so it goes
down okay so so far I've got five of my
bridges counted four so I just need to
do the other two do you see so I'm just
going to do this all the way up here and
all the way down there
okay so this is better right this is
much better I've got much less
information on there and so I can focus
on what's important maybe we should give
these guys some names so I'm going to
call these guys let's all start from the
same spot so this one seems to have the
most so I'm gonna call this guy a let's
call the top one being will just go
around in a clockwise direction a b c
and d so you see that yeah now you can
see how my edges they all sort of wiggle
around and all that kind of thing right
but we don't really care whether they go
up and down and all about we just care
which vertices they join
right so I think we can draw an even
simpler version of this where all we
focus on is a B C and D so I'm just
gonna zoom out a little bit and I'm
going to draw these big red dots again
like so and what I'm gonna ask you to
focus on as you recreate this is and I'm
gonna give you a minute to do this from
a how many edges come out from it from B
how many edges from C from D and don't
worry about how they wiggle up and down
don't worry about the geography just
worried about what's connected to what
so for example I'm gonna go and just
draw a straight line like that that's
one of the bridges from A to B right and
I don't care that it Wiggles around I
just care that it joins those two can
you finish the diagram for me you can
make a bigger or smaller it's up to you
does that look roughly similar
comparable to what you've got they make
a bit bigger bigger so I've got my four
vertices have I got the right number of
bridges right number edges you can count
them up right I go to four six seven
it's all there okay now you guys all had
trouble like all 20 of us gave this ago
and we could not work out a solution
here's I'm gonna ask you to experiment
and I'm actually gonna ask you we're all
gonna do something a bit different okay
which is going to be challenging okay I
want you to come up with your own
network any network you like just to
make it reasonably consistent I'm gonna
ask you to I have four or just to keep
things interesting if the person next to
you is using four can you use five
vertices so going ABCDE draw the
vertices any way you like join them in
as many ways as you like or as few okay
and then of the network that you draw I
want you to ask the same question right
so I don't draw the same one I want you
to draw a different one either four or
five vertices just something different
to the person see you next to you put as
many or as few edges as you like and
then see if you can cross all the
bridges without crossing any of them
twice what I expect is some of us will
create networks where it doesn't work
like this all of us will create networks
where it does work you like I'll cool
here's the path babe mmm eh I'm finished
okay then I'm gonna give that ten
minutes to do this then we're going to
draw them all up and we're gonna try and
work out is there
if yours worked why did it work and if
yours didn't work can we try and see is
there some common feature between them
does that make sense so either four or
five vertices just draw them on your
page show them as big or as small as you
like join them together once you've
drawn a network map any network diagram
you like I want you to see if you can
answer this same question okay